-You look great, as always.
You're always rocking it.
-I'm trying to be like you, bro.
-No. Come on, buddy.
Hey. Happy birthday.
Happy belated birthday.
-Thank you, bro.
-Come on, buddy.
If I know Maluma,
I know you probably just spent
a nice quiet birthday
at home, right, just chill.
-It was pretty relaxed.
-Yeah.
I have a video of you
at your birthday.
Take a look at this.
-Let me see.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, okay.
Yeah. There you go. That's --
We celebrate the same way.
We're like twins.
-Well, I told you it was chill,
it was relaxed.
At home watching movies.
-Yeah, that's all
you were doing.
What was going on there?
-Well, was in Aspen
with my friends.
I went there
for like almost two weeks.
And I was expecting that day
so bad. You can tell.
I was pouring all champagne
on me. Yeah, man, it's nice.
When you turn 28, you know,
nothing is the same.
[ Laughter ]
-You just made me so sad.
Yeah, uh...
[ Laughs ] Uh...
Last time,
we talked about your tour,
and you talked about
you're going to go
back to your hometown...
-Yes, sir.
-...in Colombia and perform.
-Yeah, have the biggest
concert of my career.
It's going to be on April 30th,
in the stadium in Medellin,
representing.
Bro, I'm so happy.
For the first time.
-Medellin.
-Yeah, for the first time,
I'm going to perform
in my hometown.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-After ten years.
-How does it feel?
How does it feel?
-I'm nervous, to be honest.
-Yeah.
-You know,
because it's not the same.
Of course, I'm very blessed --
-You don't want to mess up.
-Yeah, of course,
I'm very blessed
that I've been touring
around the world,
but nothing more important
than your hometown, bro.
So, I'm going to get there,
and I have to kill it.
-Yeah, and you're going to.
-I have to. You're coming.
-Of course. I'm there.
I'm opening.
Yeah. I know. Yeah.
I'll get some songs ready.
I'll run it by you.
-Okay.
-I'll bring the champagne.
But you're doing it
in the country's
biggest soccer stadium.
-Yes, sir.
-Which is bigger than --
We can't even imagine it
really here.
-Yeah, it's going to be like
45,000 people.
-Wow.
-So, yeah,
that's why I'm nervous.
-I was talking to you. I go,
"That's big. You're playing
this soccer stadium."
And you go,
"Yeah, I always dreamt
of being in that stadium."
I go, "Oh, that's awesome."
But not as Maluma,
not as a singer.
-Yeah, you're right, bro.
-You played soccer.
-I wanted to be a professional
soccer player when I was a kid.
So I played soccer for almost,
like, eight years of my life,
but when I turned 16 years old,
I decided to start making music,
and now we're here, man,
you know?
-Exactly.
Now you're at the stadium.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I remember I told my sister
that I wanted to fill
the stadium, you know?
I didn't know that I was gonna
do it performing as a musician.
I said, like, at the beginning,
"I'm gonna be here.
I'm gonna play soccer."
And then 10 years later
and coming back to my hometown,
going back to Medellin,
and performing for my people,
my family, man, that's in--
That's crazy.
-Can you still play?
-Yeah.
-You can?
-You? You play soccer or not?
-No. I get exhausted
watching soccer.
-Really?
-It's exhausting.
-I love playing soccer.
I still do it. I still do it.
-I mean, we have a --
I have a ball here.
-No way.
-Could you --
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay.
-Could you show me a trick
or something?
-Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-I'm feeling the pressure.
-Yeah, just pretend this
is the concert.
-The stadium.
-This is the stadium.
Everyone's -- Yeah.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-Okay.
♪♪
-Come on, bud. Come on, man.
Yeah, that's what I'm talk--
Yeah! Come on, bud!
Let's go, man.
What in the what?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-Yeah, I didn't wear a cup.
I didn't wear a cup.
That's Maluma right there.
Come on.
You know how to do it, bud.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's why I'm singing now.
-Yeah.
You just became, also,
the first recording artist
to design your own bottle
for Hennessy.
-Yeah.
-And this is a thing --
Last time you were here,
you brought me a nice bottle
of Hennessy.
And I go --
That was so nice of you.
And it's empty now, by the way.
Thank you.
We're going to debut it
right now.
-Yeah, bro, yeah, please.
-No one's ever seen this.
Please, please, please.
I want them to see it.
I want them to see it, please.
♪ Ba-da-ba-ba ♪
-♪ Da-da-da-da ♪
Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Look at it. Look at that, bud!
-Yeah, bro.
-How cool is that, man?
-You like it?
-I love it!
Dude, for being 28 years old
and you get to do this
and play stadiums, look
at what you're doing, buddy.
-Well, because
I really love Hennessy...
That's why I designed it.
-Yeah. Yeah. Me too.
I don't get to design
my own bottle. Yeah.
This looks gorgeous, bud.
-Thank you, bro.
-What goes into this?
I mean, do you look
at different things
and you make a choice and
you go, "I don't like that"?
-Yeah, remember
that I was doing
the "Papi Juancho" tour
here in the States.
So, I was using
a lot of these colors
and also trying to put
my Latin culture
and also
my Colombian culture.
I'm from Medellin, Colombia,
so I wanted just to
bring everything, what I am.
And I feel proud
to be Latin, bro,
so I put everything
in this bottle.
You can -- You can see it.
I feel proud, man, you know.
-Good for you, buddy.
I'm proud.
-Thank you, man.
-I'm proud of you, bud.
Also, I think, you know --
Not only are we besties,
but also --
-What else?
-We are also co-stars
in a movie.
-Of course, bro.
-I make a cameo
in the movie "Marry Me."
-Yes, sir.
And you killed it.
-Yeah.
-I remember.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was hard for you, no?
-It was really tough.
I played myself.
I was like, "Oh, what am I going
to be like in this movie?"
But look at you, though.
You do a voice in "Encanto,"
the biggest movie
in the world right now.
-Yeah.
-Crushing right now.
-Yeah, bro.
That movie is nice because
they're telling the true story
about Colombia.
Beautiful, beautiful things are
told in the movie "Encanto."
Because I don't want people
to think
that Colombia is Pablo Escobar
anymore and all violence.
See "Encanto," man.
It's beautiful.
-That's right.
It is beautiful.
-So I feel great to be
part of the movie, too.
You know?
-That's awesome.
Let's talk about "Marry Me."
Because I'm predicting,
right now,
this is going to start
a new renaissance
of romantic comedies, because
it's so well done, buddy.
And you and Jennifer
have chemistry.
I remember we were talking
when we shot the film here.
We shot a scene here.
And then we went to the Garden
the night before maybe?
-Yeah. The night before.
And then next day we came here.
Yeah, I remember.
-Yeah.
And you shot a scene
from Madison Square Garden.
-Yeah, man.
-How was that?
-It was nice. [ Laughs ]
-Tell the truth.
-No, no, no.
-The truth -- You want me
to tell the truth?
Well, I had fun,
I mean, it was nice.
I was performing with Jennifer.
She came like a queen,
and I just wanted to hug her,
but we had a teleprompter
because I didn't know
the lyrics of the song.
Yeah, right.
And then I started singing,
and I forgot the lyrics.
And I saw the teleprompter,
and the teleprompter went off.
[ Laughter ]
So, it was -- it was here
at the Madison Square Garden,
one of the most important
concerts of my career.
But, yeah -- But Jennifer,
she held me, man.
-She's a pro, right?
-Yeah, yeah, she got my back.
So, at the end of the day,
like, no one realized
that I didn't know the lyrics.
-It's a beautiful song, though.
It's an awesome song.
And you're actually coming back
here to perform it on Friday.
-Yeah. Yeah, on Friday,
we're going to be here.
-"Marry Me."
-I'm going to move
to the studio.
-Just live here. I'll give you
the keys to my apartment.
You can just crash tonight.
Yeah.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Maluma and Jennifer Lopez
in "Marry Me."
Take a look at this.
-♪ We could tie it up tonight ♪
♪ No patience,
Take my last name ♪
♪ Put it where your name is ♪
♪ Have they ever seen
a love this famous? ♪
-♪ They never, no, they never ♪
♪ This forever, ever, ever,
ever, ever, ever ♪
♪ Ain't nobody do it
better, better, better ♪
♪ And it's only getting better ♪
♪ True love
gotta ring, ring, ring ♪
-♪ Ooh, it gotta ♪
-♪ Church bells,
let 'em ring ring ring ♪
-♪ Ooh, they gotta, this queen
need a king, king, king ♪
-♪ For life,
for life, for life ♪
-Yes! Maluma!
"Marry Me" is in theaters
on February 11th,
also streaming on Peacock.